if all your relationships have the same
problem
you are the problem
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah um how did this one get it
yeah you know you know what's funny so
this was originally i wrote a short
article
um i wrote a short article i think in
like 2012 or 13 and it was called uh
it was called like all the reasons
you're still single
and um
[Laughter]
and i published it on valentine's day
and uh
you know i just got like a sick pleasure
out of that you know it basically said
it was like look all these problems you
think all your partners have or all the
people you date have like guess what you
know the only thing they have in common
is
common to nominate um but i i repost
that
probably about once a year in different
places and different valentine's day
just let's schedule it every february
14th from now until the end of time
i i had a pretty sick thing going on my
blog with valentine's day for a while
like
like i did that one year and then i
think the next year i did like a how to
break up with somebody
like guide on valentine's day i did like
a bunch of like kind of [__] up uh
you know dark humor type things but um
yeah i repost that one quite frequently
because
um i mean i always get
a lot of people get mad at me when i
post it a lot of you know because
everybody's got that
well you don't understand my ex is
different you know
what all four of them have the exact
same problem that you
you happen to be the single thread but
they don't know each other they're not
even in the same city
and yet they all ended in the same way
but it's all their fault not yours
yeah it's it's always i'm always uh
you know i so i get lots and lots of
emails
over the years and and i'm always amused
that the people who get really upset
at my relationship advice they're
they always send emails like this long
and it's always like well
you understand my situation is different
and then they go on the tell this like
you know five stage five page sob
story about you know
god knows what uh the and in every in
every case it's
it's exactly the same it's like no
you're you're still the problem
you're just you know um
but yeah it's also i keep posting it
because it is such a powerful
realization
um it was very powerful in my own life
uh and i've you know just heard from
hundreds of people at this point who
told me the same thing that it was very
powerful for them to hear as well
so i i'm willing to deal with a little
bit of hate um
to get the good word out doing god's
work uh right
lots of people who are still single but
want a relationship
simply have absurd expectations
yes i i think one of the problems with
uh i mean look like i think one of the
side effects of
of the internet like kind of the effects
that the internet has had on culture is
that
it's exposed us to the most
extraordinary aspects
of society you know so it's
if you're interested in uh you know
mountain climbing
you can like go on youtube and find
amazing videos of people summoning
everest like left right and center and
so
i i feel like this is without us
realizing it has skewed our expectations
for our own lives um
it's kind of like moved the goal back
about 50 yards
from where it would normally be without
us necessarily even recognizing it
and i think this applies to dating as
well it's like you you
because you have access to so many
people through dating apps or online or
or whatever you you
start developing these kind of
unrealistic standards of what a partner
should
be you know people develop these insane
checklists
of you know well they they need to be
like
they need to be a concert pianist and
they need to have a phd
and they need to be a part-time model
and they need to
speak six languages and you know it's
like
good luck man like good luck
uh so i i just i think sometimes we need
to be brought down the earth
i wonder whether as well
part of it is just that we we
constantly are looking for something
that's going to fill the hole
and perhaps by setting our standards so
absurdly high we never actually have to
enter the world of
a relationship with people also here's
another thing man
how much do you think this is because we
live in a meritocracy
like if you teach people that they can
become anything that they want to be
your success is completely yours to bear
why shouldn't
everyone want to try and date angelina
jolie well i can
become anything i want to be i can date
anyone i want to want
yeah i think it's there there's kind of
a missing counter narrative
to meritocracy or or not counter but
like a kind of a parallel narrative that
needs to exist where it's like
at some point you need to to like pick
your spot to be satisfied
what's the hill that you're going to get
married on yeah exactly exactly
exactly like it's and and this comes
back to what we were talking about
earlier about like this
this kind of unwillingness to sacrifice
and commit for others like it's
the thing that makes a relationship
strong
is the ability to be like okay i see
what's wrong with you
but i'm gonna love you anyways like that
like
getting to that point is what makes the
relationship
work um but i just think like
fundamentally the way the incentives
and culture is set up right now it's
like it's it's harder than ever for
people to get to that point
yeah you classed yourself as an ardent
zealot of marriage
um have you got any advice for young
guys who want to kind of transition from
[__] boy to fatherhood
from fuckboy to father be a good book
title it would be yeah yeah
um well i do want to say i'm not i'm i'm
not a
i'm not a zealot for marriage but like i
i think it's
underrated these days and i think
there's not enough
um people arguing for it especially
especially
in my generation um i would say
you know to make that transition it's
kind of the best piece of advice i've
come across is is asking people
you know because when you're dating a
lot of people part of the excitement
is there's so much a diversity of
dating experience like you you date
people
different backgrounds different
ethnicities different nationalities
different professions all this stuff
like it's a very exciting time to kind
of like
sample the buffet of what's out there um
but at a certain point like when you
want to get
serious the thing i always ask people is
i say like okay what are your three
non-negotiables like what are the three
things that like
you just cannot be with a person
if they don't have them and it's
i've noticed that people who really
struggle to name those three things like
they're kind of just like kind of lost
on this hamster wheel of
dating the next person who pops up on
tinder um
but like you really need to figure out
like what are your non-negotiables what
are the things that you really can't
live with out of it without in a partner
um and then figure out if those are good
non-negotiables you know there
are bad things you can kind of put in
those three spots but generally it's
gonna be stuff like
you know honesty or trustworthiness um
you know for me intelligence is huge
like i i need to people have like a good
conversation um you know and and
for me too it's it's ambition i just
find i make
very very attracted to ambitious women i
i don't
i always get frustrated you know
whenever i dated women who weren't
super ambitious i'd get very frustrated
so it's like part of it's just
learning through the act of dating but
then once you have them
you look for those non-negotiables and
then you just don't worry about the
other things
because it's i think part of the trap of
the dating environment these days is
like you know it's like well
she's really great at these four or five
things but
you know she's got pointy elbows and
i prefer redheads and you know
she's from california and i don't want
to travel to meet her family you know
like it's [__] like that that people
like
you know move on from potentially really
good relationships and so it's like
get your three non-negotiables and then
just [__] forget everything else
like just just look for those three
things
what do you think people should stop
believing about relationships are there
any sort of
common myths that you think most people
hold um i think people
mistake uh
i think people mistake compromise for
settling
um you know there's there's a strong
i've noticed that a lot of people
especially younger people have a strong
like ethos of like i'm never gonna
settle like i'm not going to settle for
somebody who like doesn't make me happy
or whatever
um and that's fine like you shouldn't
settle for
a person who you know has a like
somebody you're not attracted to
for instance um but at the same time
it's like any functional relationship
requires compromise and compromise
requires you
foregoing some of your own happiness to
create
you know more general happiness in the
among both of you in the long run and um
and i think a lot of people just mix up
those two things
you know i've i've talked to a lot of
people who who have ended relationships
for like
in my mind are just like insanely dumb
reasons you know um
it's like oh well she wanted to move you
know her uh her company wanted to move
her to another city
and i don't want to deal with that it's
like well dude you like
a month ago you were telling me how in
love you were like he's like yeah but i
don't want to settle for somebody who
like
it's just like they're not even it's
like yeah she wants me to travel there
every two months or something you know
it's like i don't have time for that
it's it's like okay this is why you're
single you're literally
you wonder why you're single decade
after decade it's because you don't
[__] prioritize your relationships
it's really simple thank you very much
for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace
you